応募僕は男子です
あなたの動画で近畿になっています動画作り頑張ってください
勉強頑張るので動画だしてください
勉強頑張れこんにちははじめ社長です
2年前やったと思うんですけども覚えてますでしょうか
あのどの買ったもの全部公会堂がー
確か前回行ったのが22点中6人の子違って31日だったんで
これまでかてきたアマゾンのもの全部見れというところだったんですけどももう2年も
経ったんでまた結構な量 amazon で買い物したわけでございますよ今回はそれ
は一つ残らず野皆さんで紹介しようと思います
あの子が基本的にネットで買い物するとき穴損でしか頼まないんで僕が出る
とで買ったものは全部 amazon だと思っていただいて結構です
[音楽]
またヤバイのかわかってるのかないやいいんですよいやその生々しさがきっと
いいんだろうねアイドルで今回も包み隠さずここ2年間アマゾンで買ったもの全部見せ
ますしかないんでね
なぜ全部見せますからねまず基本的にもうネタねぇよ
遊行カードしか買ってないですよねとあればれない鏡買ってあとためにでも買ってる
完全県がマニュアル
これ買えばためだには負けないと思ったんでしょうねあとなんかなぜかスピーカー買っ
ている
飛雄馬買ってるねーユーチューバーマガジン vol 2買ってます
また遊戯王カード乳業カード重炭酸スパークリングシャワーシャワーにつけると淡々で
しばし待って出ると思って買ったんですけどなくしました
また遊戯王カードニューマン悠遊カード入りすぎがまだ営業カード
ここなんだこれあし夜中お塩を飛ばしてショップが方で買ってみんなに言って嫌がらせ
をしてました
またいう行カードアークはボール家庭それ用のエアポンプ買って全身タイツを4つも
買ってますねポータブル電源がゲーミング散らかってここで付良かったが何かを持って
返金する ss そうケットサーキュレーターを
でから2つに分けて10個買ってます掃除機をなぜ茶っ葉
なんでいる装置付と使ったんだ覚えてねえなまず遊行カード
また水素を受けるとこの辺なんかパソコンに目覚めたんでしょうね
パソコン買ったついでにで地区も高価な通すためです来なかった中でまた遊戯王カード
また悠遊カード
血液反応液きっとあったんですけど怖くて多分使わなかっ
やってですねえっ
持って授業が友情回数がこれリッカー様の写真紹介ました
よかったですまあという今というように戻っちゃったってよれ本当にやばいなーバカな
んじゃないのをどんな eu 行しか買ってないのやばここでなきゃいけない外付け
ハードディスクを3テラ分買ってもまた優遇
ここで綱引きロープを30円待ってもどんどん怒ってんだこれよる動画に使ってないよ
やばい9億にないなんでこんなにツナ広く買ったんだったのでを計算すると30m 34
個なんで1000m して何かつなぎしようとしてなんでしょうね
まあこれ電撃が流れる目覚まし時計花火のヒナはだけ買ったあとアイビスカメラですね
いたずらグッズ買ってポケモンゴーの泡で見つけるを買ってまたいうより戻って本当に
好きだなって
ファイナルファンタジーの映画を買っていますあっハリーポッターねあのかぶってあの
どこの寮に入るか9奴がでグリフィンドールか
タックルバックかレイブンクローかスリザリンかこれを亡くしました他に良いことに
長靴って ipad のケースを書くテーマというようにもとって下駄を買いますね
アルミケース威嚇てやっぱ末シーンを犬とちょっとユーチューバーらしくなってきたん
じゃないでしょうか
デスノート買ってますね
実物買ってます頭逝ったんだ俺使ったってない記憶がもうないんだよな20000件の
本というよ凄いな
ここでエビ後ぐるみを買ってますね
なぜマッフルタンクトップ買いすぎでしょなんで最後と偏見した解析だと思ったんだと
思いますで靴とオーバー警備 c 型セットを買ってたなぁああいう指をコントロール
できないますも買ってキーボードですけどまたアイビスを買ってる
砲丸をここで4つ買ってますバカですねここらへんから中でマンガを読み始めた2
amazon でイキリ投票というのかも読んでおらへんからマン
にはまりだすんだよな確かまたやんだよね何かあってんだこれ浴槽のバスターバーター
する買って帰らのことをちょっとちゃんとしようと思って防湿効果いました半田クロス
の保湿も爆買し
トナカイを買い
ゴム授業関係靴
ドクターマー使ってますねうーんなぜか2000
16年の最後に年末で自分頑張ったということで靴をたくさん買ってます早いは
2017年見ていきましょう
お正月から自分の漫画5冊買ってなお正月から有用やる気が凄い凄い殺る気しかないや
んけああやれ
うん
週末のはりうっていう漫画がなんかすごい母れめでっ
4型でここで go pro を買ったんですよ何が使ってないんだよ
乳業の福袋くぢかって
レーザポインタバスケット basket よくがここでちょっとでちゃったんですよ
ね
けどすぐ言うように戻ってしまいましたこの空にグルってがすごい面白かったです発
前後のませんこってますね
何やってんですよ2005発展だラーメン食いたくてラーメンて使い心にからなんか
映画に協業もチャンス目てんのかな ufo ソープポンプ
3つ買ってます
あ
[音楽]
懐かしいボジョレーヌーボー買ったんですよこれなんかボトルがすぐじゃんってなっ
てるからおーすげー
流れなんかこれが多分曲がる関係で一緒に買ったんでしょうね
またいう業界ドローンを買ってますここで iphone ケースと新しいの買います
友情
基本的な心サポートだっての基本的にお湯行しか買ってないのかもしれないなか女性
っている賭博が石ブロックも書くが医師
巨大の enter キーを買い今た遊戯王を買ってますどうぞなんか電子ピアノ等と
思って全然ピアノ方で買って版白緑10度カメラもう買ったけど結局使うことなく
電撃殺虫ラケットをも売ってる分全種類買いフェイクダイナーないと回ゴールデン
タイムの漫画の休館だけ持ってなくてそれだけ買いましたぜれにっていう漫画をかい
りゅう業関係がこういうの学校の怪談4
入ってますゼルダの伝説の一番くじの d 賞わざわざかいいできる3愚痴らまだか
良い音とレンジとまたカメラっ
のやる気が出てすげーな客5人 youtube っぽいな話切っくそーバンクがいい
し日焼けしたくないんですけど日焼け止め塗るのも嫌だったんできやけ止めののムンの
開花もと日に起こっているのは無数の用いた0
ファイアーパンチっていうね漫画すっごい面白かったんだよこれ南長崎漫画にハマっ
てるのはこの時期ならない方に下がってるぺ暗号化いいい
僕らへんなから痛々しい中
家になったんでしょうね一方で電子タバコか一回もさんたくさんかいいここでノー服を
買ったんですよ
ベンチのそっかもモブ子が来て前になるのか
今地下で寝てますチャーペンここで買ってるのはジェノサイダーってなんだこれ
いやねまた何かとと
ソイエロの漫画を読み勝ちなんですよ血が出るカプセルピルを買った後に
ジャグマンガ日和ですかねこれは器具マンガ日和なに目を見た後に英霊化成分を確か
一気見したんすよねここら辺で売るか7号ミッチ右手になったら夏菜で彼に困ってか
トレイルを買い
また再びエウレカセブンに戻りれかすみまくってこのままたの最終回
で見てしまった流れですねゴキブリ校で開幕で伊勢 d 深いのがまたユーチューバー
ぽくなっていったと虹郎って突然の映画部分がまた来ますので呪文
見てデジモントライを見てバイオハザードを見てララランドここで見たんですね穴に
ブリリアントパークっていうのが遊園地を経営するラーメンにはまっ
ねまた見てます母と子のふくうんでコレなにこれ
稲川淳二の心霊通信見てますねん甘ブリは面白かったですよでホーム中の菌がの卵首本
カメラ買ってコンテナ回出していきなりとらドラでセンター元の頃見て解くカード整理
しようと思って遊行カード解析言ったじゃないですか見たとおりだから悠遊カード
入れる為の
なんかこういう大容量の本棚を買いましたグレネード天使
良い道野菜でを会まずいう業界剥離ここでこたつでしたこのなんかオサレなメタリック
のゴミ箱回恐竜になりたかったでしょうねハロウィンアリーナ座に恐竜になって街
暴れようと思ったんですけどもにはなかったんで諦めた思い出があります
またいう気を張ってるわ活魚熱が出てきて
おっ
てい
みんな勘違いしないですね動画コンテストにあってそれであの jk 達が出演して
欲しくてあのその後立つように政府を買ったんですよ
決して僕の趣味ではありませんあのこれらに言ってなかったんですけどズレマスターで
ちょっとやろうかなと思って10万にちょっとだけ工程だしちゃったんですよでも
やっぱり友情が良かったみたいですね言われない
国会稲中かいますねアイスクリーム買ってるんだこれ
学ランが入るともで書く欄を各社でしてハガレンの服ですねは結構最近ならこれも
baby driver っていうですねあの映画がすごい面白かったので是非とも見
ていただきたいですね g ミネーションバックが石塊します向けの道路を作ってここ
でエアポッツを買ってますね去年な最後は選ぶ大塚
終わってんだなぁこれの僕のルード第5区の文化って言いますはいでは2018年です
2018年なんでも
はじめにサッカーがこれならフィッシュが競ってたなぁ買ったんだけどなんか微妙だ
からそのままお蔵入りにしてしまいました5品業界
チーズをかいいいなんかななぜか服に目覚め恵ちゃんここで買ったんですねそう今年
買ったのか恵ちゃんこれ1冊かとマスターボールが付いてくるんですよってこで l
マンガ先生を回復が欲しいと思ってナノユニバースの福袋みたいなのかっ
てお正月を過ごしていました入ったまた有料時代が来てまだゴーグルを買ったんです
けどなんかいろいろあって止めて言うように戻り
7つの滞在を見まくってますね2期が始まったんだな謎の滞在の任期が始まったから見
なきゃと思ってここからまた観始めました
なる教会やサリーンのねサリーのさ選手を買ったわけです ske のアント
夏に配るために4ず使いました中に限定が入っているナマズシーンだけ僕を改造しまし
たありがとうございますってここでちょっと落とし物がひどいということに気づいて
忘れ物しないために分失望せたグっていうのを買いましたこれをどこかに失くしました
またいうように戻り
の号プロポの正式にひーろしく回ぺーピアスをたくさん買って結界先生にはまったわけ
ですよ
めっちゃ恐るべき店舗が入って大人いいてが中の空気感で雰囲気が好きです空気清浄機
を買いまくり花粉の季節になったからてまたちょいちょい夏の滞在と見ながら6ペア爆
買して
でこっから州でちょっと畑が始まったんでなんか全部の macbook を買ったり
してました
みんなこう分かりやすいようにカバー男もかっ
てビートに2つにはまりだすいない中ブギも買ったりして
ギャグマンガ日和にまたはまりちょっとネタバレにちょっと本物どうあるネタバレに
なるものがあるんでちょっと隠しながらいきますね
まずはカメラを買ったりして品なんかな
この犬の顔すごいですよねはいこんな元でございますすっち見てみてわかったことは
遊戯王カード大スギ
[音楽]
me
バッハ